[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we're asking the questions
that you ask us and then we're answering
them because anything goes oh yeah we've
opened up the floodgates and the
questions just rolled right in anything
anything at all we're going to answer
what we're gonna well we're the ones
that we pick yeah we're answering ask us
anything we'll answer some but it's very
the way we pick these things is very
loose it's like it's so you're like oh I
picked some I picked some and we don't
win we don't discuss it ahead of time I
don't know I don't know you I don't even
know my answers honestly yeah I'm kinda
like well maybe maybe something will
come to me yeah for a lot of these but
before we do that we will let you know
that we're both about to head out oh you
giving them a warning Spring Breaks
I'm excited at the end of this recording
session I'm on vacation oh you're
getting a little bit of a sermon started
that's right you uh you didn't you
didn't we didn't consult on this however
you are going international so you think
so you have yeah travel to travel days I
just flip you the bird what do you got
it's just ie sign backwards you coming
in you coming in - were coming in hot
you coming into work tomorrow
I'm not coming in I don't know we didn't
consult I guess I need you to come in if
I'm not going I will be working tomorrow
yes you're working you know I'll be
thinking about things if that's your
question
I just whether or not I'm here but you
know what you know what don't work no
those days when you're when you're not
here and I feel like I got this big old
office to myself that's pretty nice I
play I play all the music that I want as
loud as I want I I fart openly you know
it's nothing there's nothing less that
things happen in there were here you
haven't said anything that you don't do
anyway like we had a meeting right
before this that is true right before
this recording session we had a meeting
which was preceded by us working at our
desks independently for about two hours
and they could you know they come into
the meeting and then Jacob looks like it
smells funny in here that was
farts you know the first thing I thought
well we've been farting in here well
we've been playing a game before tennis
where we that does digest face we face
back to back and I don't know it's like
yeah we just have like a fart fart verse
a [ __ ] like the fart that you ripped
yesterday it sounded like you were
squishy is that is that chair is the
acoustic quality of that chair that is
it like it's it's almost a musical
instrument the way it propels it out
into the middle of the room
I think it's designed yeah I think that
is a design to shoot your farts out you
just tell me your farts out into the
middle of the fart share and so it'll be
like an hour of fart a cello and you
play the music you want to play fart a
horn Rhett plays this like Garnett
Barnett Rhett plays this I don't know
it's it's like concentration music it's
no no no it's got some beats in it no
it's uh it's low five 24/7 which if you
just google low five 24/7 you'll get and
there's a few YouTube channels and this
is a mythical beast suggestion back
there's a wreck this is what this was a
wreck to me from the mythical beasts
I've talked about it on the show before
I think cuz I was like what's some good
like right music because I don't like
lyrics in my music when I'm writing and
because I start just writing the lyrics
speaking of recommendations some of that
been meaning to do but haven't done for
many episodes now is say that hey if you
listen to the end of an ear biscuit we
are now doing a recommendation oh you
already know that though because you're
not you're not the kinds of people that
stop listening so listen to the end and
we're we're alternating episodes
throwing out our recommendation it's a
wrecks in effect but anyway we're
heading out
yeah well your point I'm still on the
fart story okay you're playing the music
which it's not like you don't play what
you want o me there you played a museum
oh five 24/7 yeah and then we're like
what it's just straight extreme quiet
yeah actually yesterday where wasn't any
music because the all of a sudden it was
just but music mm-hmm from you and like
I just you wait hadn't talked for an
hour and we're just sitting there
working on stuff that makes things up
sometimes just kind of we started
laughing it was it was very far too
funny Thursday
we've established that we've established
that farts are funny
and I have you don't think so
something's wrong with you my abdomen is
cramping hard and I might have to add
some music to the mix oh yeah I'm in
pain right now but it might be negative
pressure it might not be positive
pressure anyway so when when Jacob came
in and he was like something it smells
like it smells like something's rotting
in here and then Josh said it smells
like cruciferous vegetables he was right
because there was cabbage inside the
dish that you had sealed up and I'd put
it in the trashcan
so it wasn't our farts and I was glad
that we didn't say well we've been
farting it up for the past two hours
yes he's my office anyway
we are heading out we've talked I'm
going I'm doing another ski trip you're
doing another London II trip and by
London II trip I'm going to going to
London
you're not just going to late London
North Carolina there probably is one uh
yeah for Lily's 16th birthday we're
taking we taking her wherever she wanted
to go it's like we had this grand idea
that now I we're gonna have to do for
the other children if I don't know what
oh yeah yeah or or like YouTube shuts
down and our entire you know our entire
financial ecosystem crumbles and then
I'll be asking my 16 year old son did to
house me oh that's it would be quite a
turnaround yeah
are you like you're looking forward to
it the financial crumble of my London
yes if she wanted to go to London we're
gonna do the Harry Potter stuff I'm sure
I'll give you a full rundown on the
backend but you know having having had
our complete London rundown I'm prime my
expectations are primed and I I know I I
know how I'm gonna approach it yeah
dinner every night at Slug and Lettuce
the food aspect of it stuff like that
but yeah very excited I think it's gonna
be a very special it's designed to be a
special like memory forming occasion for
us with just Lily not with the boys not
being there lots of mental pictures and
lots of actual pictures yeah man
no injuries no snow no mountains no be
safe man no but I you know I I heard
tell that your wife is she's a little
anxious because these planes have been
falling out of the sky all over the
world and she's got it now getting one
and go across the ocean well we're not
on that plane and that planes been
ground that place around it but plane
we're not on that plane but James she
has a borderline phobia right and it's
like and this is in the news she's
taking that into what what a difficult
week what's your plan she's had a
difficult week
Asajj take a massage tool hand holding I
guess try not to sleep poetry I'm trying
not to sleep until she sleeps but she's
not she's not gonna sleep and you're
gonna sleep immediately like literally I
was thinking about this on our last our
last trip this is why I always test not
pictures of you regardless of how long
the flight is is that every single time
we get on the plane and then they start
like the beverage service or if there's
a meal involved yeah you sleep through
that part like it's your you fall it
because typically that's like we've
reached 10,000 for whatever the feed is
10,000 feet and now the Wi-Fi is working
and like we're kind of leveling out and
they're starting to bring the beverages
out you're gone and so last time we were
flying I woke you up because I was like
this can't happen again now one time you
laid down and put the sleep mask on and
slept right through the thing and then
you wake up in your life it's their
dinner you know it's like seven hours
into the flight and they were like uh
well not anymore something about
something about getting in the air makes
me sleepy so you gotta you gotta take
you get or take a Red Bull you got to do
a Red Bull before you get on the plane
if you don't wanna fall asleep I do want
to fall asleep but I'm gonna I'm gonna
try to stay awake for Christie and
cheesy I mean she's got there's like
she's been given some like meditation
guided meditations that she can go
through for like some positive oriented
some like well they're all positive
some some very negative some folks it's
not my sound of screaming people have
planes crashing careening out of the sky
this is what could be happening right
now
but it's not actual all of that wood
worm from failed water landings sure
this is certain people might be into
that okay I'm sure there are
because sometimes I tell my wife I'm
like when she's upset with me I'm like
you know I mean you know what I could be
doing right now
and then I like make up a crazy scenario
that's a lot worse than what I am doing
yeah and she's like this reasoning
doesn't work yeah that's called
deflecting into the abyss like usually
you deflect to something that's like
also concrete like I could be in prison
right now right okay all right but I'm
not she's like that just does that
effectively I could be a murderer right
I'm not that insensitive yeah yeah I
could be living a double life I know I
know that's funny but I also feel like
maybe you said that because it is kind
of funny but you know you're like yeah
perspective right yeah you get sometimes
you gotta yeah we could be crashing
right now we're not that's if everything
goes right Lu ways you say that to your
wife I here's a simple one you want to
wait why don't we why don't you take a
small break and then and then and then
answer a question I'm gonna ask the
question Oh and it'll be like he either
got it Sarah a one four two two six six
oh nine five whoa asks what's the
strangest thing you've ever found the
other person doing when you walked into
the room Oh hashtag your biscuits you'll
get that answer and more in a second but
first you can get my shirt and Lynx hat
part of our story we're collection the
post apocalypse
where does apocalypse apocalypse where
dogs take over you got this smiling with
human esque teeth why I keep chompers is
a his name happy Chomper happy chompers
happy I love this hat because something
about the the materials with which it's
made it's like it's the it's very
pleasing it's very light like I like the
material easing material it's got a it's
got a captain's kow captain's rope and
it's just it just it props up there and
it props up there lots of great features
I have a shirt that features Instagram
this is a dog Hume dog or as I said the
first time I read the script for the
voice-over hum dog but it's actually a
human dog and Instagram get it he's an
Instagram dog and he got that many licks
instead of likes get it what do you
think of the of the collection jade is
all of the proceeds go to us and then
because we love our dogs so much they
benefit that's right so if you want our
dogs to community eat and be healthy and
get their like shots and vet visits you
need to buy this Virge right yeah yeah
we will stop giving we will stop giving
the dogs their regularly scheduled you
know vet recommended veterinarian things
if you do not buy these shirts they'll
get heartworms is what we're saying okay
if you don't want our dogs to have
heartworms buy these shirts you know I
heard that heartworm is normally happen
anymore your dog your dog Tucker died of
heart worms it definitely happened to
him and and that I guess because of the
medication and stuff that just squarely
our fault but our varible about that our
vet said something about how oh yeah I
mean you don't have to really worry
about those anymore you still take it
but it's not really to calm really yeah
okay I give her the medicine strangest
thing I've seen you doing what alright
so yeah so we're and we're answering
your questions now here it is we're
getting into it well made it through the
ads the thing that this makes me think
about is the fact that you know we have
our secret lost our not-so-secret loft
especially if you remember the mythical
Society you
you've seen that loft and the mythical
addresses but both of us independently
sometimes might get hurt early and might
use the loft for meditative purposes hmm
was a meditation cushion up there and
I've walked in and I was like I see your
car when I get here vice versa same
things true you walk in lights are on
you know somebody's in the office but
and then you kind of like settle down
into your desk and then I hear the
nostril flap it's a little breathing now
I at least I at least say when you walk
in I'm I'm here I'm here I'm here I'm
here I'm here I'm meditating it's a
little weird to walk in on somebody
meditating but you can't see them right
especially here briefly because we do it
nude mm-hmm I've never meditated nude
you should try it
we just think I've seen you do when I
walk in on you it's like when we're like
traveling or like and then I'll get up
in the morning you're like down on the
floor and your underwear like doing some
sort of contortion like I was like dude
you sleep on the floor last night I was
like in an in it it's like you fell off
you fell out of a skyscraper and like
splattered on the ground I'm prejudiced
I'm like gosh what what happened man and
then I realize you're like doing your
stretching oh gosh I'm do you know what
in the stretches you do are weird well
they're their doctor and physical
therapist prescribed I'll tell you one
thing they are they have gust in your
boxers it's just I don't want to see
that you don't have to watch why don't
you watch I just saw some people would
pay to well that that's the weirdest
thing that I find I might start a
YouTube channel that's just called
retching which is Rhett and stretching
mixed together it's not throwing up
because it's built our H E
TCH ing retching rats trechie 24/7 it's
a it's a it's a live stream and I'm
listening to 24/7 lo-fi
inception I think that's the weirdest
thing I mean what hold on but have you
seen me pick my nose I'm do that every
day this is my stretching I was thinking
I was thinking about this I was thinking
about this this morning I was having a
conversation with my pilate's instructor
and it was I'm spending a lot more time
with my stretches and not just my
stretches but the the the rolling on the
ball thing you know I got a little
lacrosse ball and I like getting into
all the different nooks and crannies of
my back and all the places that there
are knots and I have discovered that
especially getting ready to go ski for a
week I'm like a lot of times when I get
ready to transition into something I'm
about to go on vacation my back gets
tight in anticipation of it's a weird
stress thing that happens mm-hmm and
also you don't want to be out there
having paid all this money for the ski
vacation and it not be fees enough not
be able to ski so I've been rolling my
back out in upper mid and lower with
this ball well that every single morning
that's a weird thing to walk you know
because it just looks like you're you're
wallowing around and also flunking
noises like this is what retching the
retching channel would be would just be
me laying on the ground one you look you
probably look like a guy who's just
[Applause]
because it's good you yes yes yes yes
because it the pain is helping me the
pain is so intense but it's unraveling I
don't know how the science works it's
doing something to the muscle knots
releasing them making me feel good
anyway I think actually hurting my life
I actually heard that rolling out is now
not it's not proven to be as effective
as active stretching it's not proven to
be as effective for recovery for rivalry
isn't that true
I don't know next question I'm rolling
out for a different reason I'm rolling
out four knots I'm not rolling out for
recovery like to weigh your work my
lavish laude not lavish Lionel asks I
was recently asked when you died if you
were offered to view a top-five list of
some moments in your life which list
would you choose
personally I'm leaning towards the top
five times I was closest to death do you
say towards or toward when you write
towards that is incorrect for I don't
write it first
I know write it for you for just say it
well what I realized was happening I was
looking at our editor who had gone
through the Google Docs where we wrote
our novel mm-hmm and all the towards had
been changed to toward oh yeah because a
lot of nice words is the UK really in
which that's what I say I always add the
s but technically the u.s. which I don't
know why we got so much beef about
little things like that like you got
y'all don't have an S
we got an it's right it's right here for
heat but it's wrong for there and
there's another was another weird word
Oh
vice like okay vice-like grip okay
vice-like grip is a word is a phrase
vice - like that is in low base is a
lost causes oblique rig it's it's a in
and so how would you spell vice like
with the - vice - how I spelled ice Oh
v.i.c wrong yeah it's BISE in America a
vice in America with a/c is like a moral
vice it's like some part of you that's
compromised by the tool but a tool in
America is with an S and in the UK it's
with us see both ways what is the world
coming to why do we have so many
disagreements why can't we just make a
decision we have enough for that just to
be I mean you got to keep standards of
the language is gonna fall into chaos
but let's get to this question when you
died you were offered to view a top-five
list man I think I think that would be
that would be frustrating to only see
five moments that's that's that's a sure
that's your complaint I mean I would be
grateful for seeing anything I watch
five would you try oh I'm still able to
see I'm not you know I'm not nothing
there is an afterlife
so check but we'd start but what would
you well oh and now I get to see five
things I want to see the happiest
moments of my life I would have but what
if it's a hill from that then that might
make you sad it's like because I
actually think his answer is pretty
lavish Lionel had a pretty good answer I
want to see the top five times I was
closest to death well and but couldn't
see the ones I was the my answer was
closest to death that I did not realize
oh yeah that's that that's what I
thought was implied and I think that I
think he has the best answer because
sorry for taking it lavish but hey props
to you cuz then you're really grateful
it's like man I could have gone five all
the times yeah it was turns out I had
six lives like a cat anything you know
like a like a shortchanged cat and what
kinds of things were those B I mean it
wouldn't it wouldn't be the most obvious
things like you think it would be things
like well there was this one time that
it would you almost hit by a rig it
would be something like there was this
one time where this virus that would
have gone into your brain and started
eating away at it you washed your hands
you've washed your hands exactly the
right below your nose knees and if you
hadn't a sneezed you would be dead oh
wow
there's B it'd be something like that or
there was a moment in which some little
platelet inside one of your veins
could have gotten stuck and caused a
stroke I don't know what but it's but it
but it just skated by yeah and it would
be like I caught that clot went the
wrong there be a most boring video in
history but it you're just watching a
vein what am I supposed what am I seeing
here what am i senior oh the platelet
good with the other way you would have
died closest to death but I would still
be very grateful to not have died sooner
and whereas with my initial answer of
the happiest moments that would probably
just make me so sentimental and sad but
what you said reminded me of the other
night you know it's like we had 30
minutes before it was bedtime I was like
oh we don't we could watch him we could
watch one episode of a sitcom but I'm
just gonna throw on YouTube and see
what's what's going on and there was
like this trending video that was
sportscasters getting upset part two and
I'm like this is trending so it was like
new and fresh probably hadn't seen it
and I like you watch this as a family
news book this is mean Lincoln land oh
and Britain and I started watching that
one in it sucked and then Britain was
like you know what you should put on
clothes calls from failarmy oh gosh this
is great and then I'm like this sounds
like a good idea well it wasn't a good
idea because you stressed out you're
sitting there and it's just like a lot
of traffic footage of like okay here's
just an intersection and rush and all of
a sudden you see this motorcycle instead
of stopping like he didn't know how to
use his motorcycle and like he flips
over the hand the handlebars and then he
just walked away and as he flips over
and tumbles into the intersection a car
is barrels through there and just misses
running over it again close call huh it
was a close call yeah I mean the good
news is you know everybody makes it
because it's a close call it's not like
morbid shouldn't actually be on YouTube
and can't stay up there look at that
feels like it would be rewarding to
watch
well the cumulative effect of like
seeing like a guy in a cowboy hat with
his daughter like looking this where's a
train where's the train and like you can
look Oh past the guy see the train is
coming and you're like you're standing
come on the wrong way on the rail you're
standing like halfway and at the last
second he turned cuz he heard it and got
out of the way but it was a close call
very close call I mean that was
disconcerting man and all to all types
of these things it's just it just made
me think ever since then if I'm walking
on a sidewalk I'm like what if I trip
you've seen the videos alike you know
there were these two girls walking down
the street on the sidewalk and the one
girl just like hip-checked her friend
just to be cute and the girl falls out
into the street and like a big freakin
bus comes by and like just barely misses
running over her her noggin close call
it was a close call
miraculously caught miraculously time to
miraculously call them all right open
clawed yeah man it was yeah I was like I
got a
this off and they weren't censored
either so there was I mean sometimes
with it with a close call there's
there's lots of colorful language that's
used so watch out for that do you have a
wreck light for later because like
because because you made me think of a
wreck based on what you just said
watching something with your family it's
yeah save your wreck well if it's
related Oh give it I don't feel my wreck
I have a wreck my wrecks are not worthy
of the final ray give it now this is a
prereq it's in effect
Goldbergs as a elevation television show
which incidentally our own Shane top is
a series guest star regular something
whatever you would say Smosh Shane yeah
yeah I've only watched it was in a Thai
restaurant last night they were playing
Goldbergs and I said I told Christy I
was like see that guy right there that's
Shane he's in he's in Smosh I think that
you're it's just a good it's it takes
place you know the premise it takes
place in the 80s but it's just a family
being a family and I thought it was the
90s actually it's the 80s actually yeah
it's the 80s I mean maybe maybe it's
some season it goes I don't know how
many seasons there it'll get there but
it might be in the 90s but you know you
recommend in the show or something else
I'm recommending the show okay I'm
recommending the show to watch as a
family because we said there is a family
and realized how like all these every
member of the family is like a
caricature of a mom and a dad but it's
also based on this dude's life that
creator of the show Adam Goldberg and
okay but anyway it was just like I see
how I fall into the bad trope and you
know the mom falls into the mob trope
kids fall into the kids trope and anyway
it's a wreck what about near near-death
experiences made you think of that you
said you would set down and what we have
half an hour to watch a sitcom as a
family oh I was gonna say okay if you're
in the mood for a half-hour sitcom
Goldbergs is a wreck let's ask another
question though
taco Picasso highly-educated with an ex
asks how do you cheer yourself up when
you're feeling sad
your biscuits the first thing I think of
is music like music can help snap me out
so like I can like I can go with like
some bangers like give me that banger
playlist just example Miley Cyrus party
in the USA yeah right that's it
I listen to that song and tell me you
say it's not catchy it is a happy happy
song that was someone would make you
happy I do not recommend the song happy
because it's those two on the notes laid
out party in the USA is a bit tired but
I probably always work yes it's not a
wreck I'm not making a wreck man it
likes making a ref a reference the thing
that I do when I'm feeling sad lately is
actually yeah you know when well no I've
there are times when I feel sad in
general not maybe I don't think more so
lately but when I said lately I meant
lately I'm trying to not say oh I feel
sad I'm going to play party in the USA
but instead just leaning into it and
saying you know what let's get Saturday
if it's a little sad let's just go ahead
and let's experience the the entire wave
of that emotion yeah and instead of
trying to fight it so interesting enough
yesterday morning coming into work you
know Spotify will create based on what
you've listened to they'll and I'm sure
all of the streaming services do it
they'll like create this automated
playlist for the AI man yeah and I've
been listening to more some more moral
lately and back in the moral and well
and there's a sad part to that too like
I the other night I was listening to and
I texted you about this I was I was
listening to Ben Haggard Merle Haggard
youngest son who who we know and who got
us into his cars who basically enabled
us to meet Merle
before he passed away a little over a
year ago I guess it's been maybe longer
now he's been two years yeah and I
hadn't realized even though you told me
this that he does some covers on his
Instagram I guess that's another wreck
follow Ben Haggard on Instagram tell him
that we sent you
Rhett link sent me big fan or whatever
he does covers of he just like sits in
his in an intimate space like his living
room or something with this one studio
mic and covers lots of lots of stuff but
Merle songs and I did not realize Kristi
said hey listen to this I saw it on
Facebook cuz your mom had posted it your
mom had posted a Ben Haggard cover of
her merle song and she and she's like
commenting he's friends with rhett and
Link and like she's like commenting oh
thanks book about it and was really cute
and so Kristi's telling me this and she
starts playing the song and I'm just
listening to it and I was like well this
is Merle this is this is actually not
Ben this is actually this is just a
moral song that's being played but then
she showed me the video I'm like no this
has been and I think it sound just like
he can sound I mean we know Merle
Haggard so well that like all the entry
into Chrissa teas what's the word
intricity intricity yeah of his his
vocal deliveries intricity I can't say
it well intricate is the inter-cities
intricate intricity is that how you say
it intricity an interest in true kiss
--'tis what is the word interest let
there's four people in this room and no
one else can say it interest cities and
no one wants to try to say it whatever
intra kissa t that's not right it's
definitely not intricate cities is
that's that's the one thing that I know
is not in chicka titties and Ruger did
is guess the new eyes got intricate it
is you wouldn't believe it of his of
murrells vocal delivery he can nail to
the point
of here's what happened tell me what
once I realized that it was been singing
I just sat there and listened to it
and my eyes welled up with tears and I
started crying yeah I get that I could
not I was just it was as if the ghost of
Merle had come back it was and you know
what I was I was just blown away with
the wave of emotion and I and I think I
realized at that moment I don't think I
ever fully mourned the loss of Merle
like when like I didn't really sit down
and listen to the extent that I should
have like just go through the the
morning of losing this guy like I was
telling Britton about and he was like
yeah when Tom Petty died I sat in my
room and and bawled my eyes out I cried
myself to sleep literally and he was
like and it took a long time because I
was playing this one song on YouTube and
I had to press play every I had replay
every time it stopped and that was also
related to the fact that he had never
seen him live or something or hit him or
because Britain goes to a bunch of
concerts and so not have he had never
gotten to see him right and like coach
Brandel my soccer coach in college I
mean in high school I did not cause I
was flush he talked about when
what's-his-name from the Grateful Dead
died he was a dead Jerry Garcia that
like he lit candles and like listen to
the music and his ball his eyes out and
I thought that sweet but I would never
see myself doing that and I think you
get it I was late in bed listening to
Ben sing Merle and like I just started
crying and then I went on his YouTube
page and started looking at the comments
and I felt validated that a lot of
people were commenting that they were in
tears like as a morning exercise but
anyway all that's backstory to I started
listening to more moral because I'd
realized that
since his death I'd kind of been
avoiding listening to him I think just
not wanting to go there but I started
listening to him and then Spotify
started recommending Merle and other
country music people as a certain
playlist so I played that on my way into
work yesterday morning and somehow he
went from Merle to like some Travis
Tritt song there's a great deal of
talking about growing a fu-manchu's kind
of a hokey song but yeah I like Travis
good shout out to Travis Tritt happy
song and then the next one it played I
looked over intricacies intricacies
that's what I was saying the whole time
we wanted some extra syllables in there
jen is afraid to say it but she spelled
it out so that we could read it you say
it yeah yeah intricacies the freaking
voice of the AI and that in Independence
Day the more they of in intricacy this
is the voice of the orb intricacies so
then I look at the next song and I see
it pops up Diamond Rio the song was one
more day do you remember this one more
day one more night one more sunset maybe
I'd be satisfied but then again I know
what it would do leave me wishing still
for one more day with you and I you know
I heard the first chord and I'm like I
immediately like reached for the skip
I'm like I am NOT doing this and I
reached for it and just as my finger
touched the skip forward button cuz I
wasn't gonna listen to the Travis Tritt
song again I was gonna go forward I was
like you know what no I'm gonna do this
I'm like in all that bumper-to-bumper
traffic in Glendale you know ten lane
highway listening to it and it's
basically about like if I had one wish
granted to me I would wish to have one
more day with the person who this loved
one who had apparently passed away and
let me tell you
I bawled my eyes out
I've never this is I've never done this
to Diamond Rio yes like I was crying
like I was doing that ugly cry were like
your hope your face shrivels up on my
way to work and I had my like I had to
prop my elbow up and like put my hand
over my face so it looked like I mean it
my face shriveled up and teeth like
tears rolling down both eyes man I think
there might be something else your eggs
your excess well I mean it made me think
of loved ones I've lost and I thought
about it specifically and like you know
so I listen to the whole song and cried
like I'm like a baby well you know
ironically and I didn't even wipe the
tears away it was one of the you know
what I let him fall ironically and
fittingly I feel like there's two sides
of this coin there's the leaning into it
yeah and then there's the coming out of
it and I think that I've got something
for coming out of it okay great you know
a little bit about this but so one thing
I'll say I think the first thing that I
thought when I looked at this question
was I think that I and again I talked
about this i prime I feel like I'm
talking about the fact that I go to
therapy every single podcast at this
point so sorry if that's annoying to you
but I think traditionally my answer to
this would be like hmm sad what is that
you know I'm saying like because I know
that I do get sad but I tend so in my
head right I think that both i transmute
my emotion of sadness into other things
like anger probably or like yelling at
the kids or something because yeah I
don't process and actually like you said
lean into the sadness and like let it
run its course because I do think that
sadness is a part of the human condition
and something that we should not run
from but assuming that you you you've
let it run its course
music I think is a way to bring you out
of it now I want to talk to you about a
guy
named dr. fun and there's probably other
there's probably a rapper out there
named dr. fun and other people named dr.
fun so you may not get this guy if you
just google dr. fun but so our good
friends lance and Lacey who beard and
lady if you're if you're a real mythical
beasts you know about lance and Lacey
and beard and lady they make the lip
balm and the beard oil in the pomade
great friends back in North Carolina
and look they're just both crazy in the
best possible way like lance and Lacey
are just there in the interesting stuff
and they'll just start telling you about
something that happened in them or
somebody they know and it's gonna be
interest they're enthusiastically open
and it's not it's it's always refreshing
to have those people in your life yeah
and Lance will just text me out of the
blue he texted me texted me recently and
he said I think that you're now ready
for dr. fun like okay and then he just
sends me like he's been sitting on an
octa phone for a while he sends me a
facebook video of this guy his name is
Tim McGinnis McGinnis and that's mcgi
in in is AKA dr. fun now Lance knows
this guy now when you say aka dr. fun I
just want to clarify that his YouTube
channel is Tim McGinnis aka dr. fun yes
all of that that's it and this guy Lance
knew him Lance lived out here in
California for a while before we ever
did in fact when we met him in North
Carolina he was moving back from
Pasadena and he knew this guy in
Pasadena I don't know exactly how they
got to know each other Bree said I knew
this guy when I lived in in California
and he's just a this super enthusiastic
guy who is it makes all this original
music that is designed to like focus
your mood in the right direction and but
you he said in one time he recorded my
mouth trumpet and incorporated it into a
song like just to give me an idea the
kind of guy that
your phone is he's like he knows that
you can do the masturbating Lance can do
a mean mouth trumpet I can know a mean
mouth crowd yeah so anyway he just sends
me so what dr. Funt dr. fun now it
sounds like you're saying two things
which I don't think are true and that's
one that he is like some sort of
therapist that too is residing in
Pasadena California no no at this point
dr. fun dr. fun met a lady and they mrs.
fun they moved to Cabo San Lucas where
we you know we've been to Cabo in fact
speaking of watermelons on shirts yeah
see what'd you do what'd you do in there
a mythical beast gave me this shirt on
tour might have given it to you guys too
small they moved to Cabo and he I don't
know what he does besides he has this
thing on Facebook that he calls the dr.
fun Institute for intentional thought
transformation and as far as I can tell
one of the main tenets of the Institute
for intentional thought transformation
is to sing these songs that are almost
like mantras to get you in the right
mood I mean listen he'll go on the
rooftop of his home in Cabo San Lucas
and just this is an 18 minute video and
he's just going through
he's just singing these songs making him
up on the spot or accessing them from
his library I don't know anything else
about your library like his brain his
brain library so before you play it I
just want to clarify that this is just a
dude with he looks like he could be
ex-military he's got a like close
cropped hair he's wearing a black
t-shirt probably shorts probably
barefoot he's not in a clinical
environment he's filming himself on an
iPhone vertically in like vlog format
and it's very extemporaneous let me just
tell you not plan that these songs have
been in my head and I have found myself
when my I'm not kidding you when my I
start like thinking things or whatever
I'm like I feel a little bit down a
doctor fun song comes into my mind and I
just started singing it and it's it does
the trick you guys in his system
she is my superpower appreciation got me
feeling high appreciation is my
superpower okay one more time he had
already said one more time so I'm just
gonna go - how many times does he say
one more time
he just he'll look off into the distance
and then another one will come out he
finds joy in all the things around him
one more time I find the best feeling
thought for feeling good right now and I
focus focus focus on feeling good right
now there's more it didn't need to and
I'm just gonna go swirling all around
you just relax and let it flow I'm just
going to a random spot 18 minutes and
this is just he does this like every
other day got a drunk good right now
there's no need to wait
oh here's the tape I'm gonna feel good
right now need to wait or hesitate I
don't feel good right now need to wait
hesitate I'm gonna feel good right now I
mean and how many views is this F 1111
views guys I think it's about to have
more and less my theory dr. fun is
giving you the musical mantras that you
need on the back side it's at there's
another song where he's like he's
walking down the streets in Cabo San
Lucas and he's doing this head thing
he's like shift shift shift my
perspective till I'm feeling good I'm
gonna share share shifted my perspective
feeling a feeling good I'm like and then
I find myself singing this song I'm
gonna shift shift shift my perspective
till I'm feeling good and you just bet
it works
it does work it's magic dr. fun is magic
because there's just you know it's
scientifically proven that just smiling
makes you feel better right just the act
of smiling even if it's a forced smile
your body begins to do the things
emotionally that is associated with the
smile and dr. fun has got this institute
man I mean it's again it's the instant
dr. Funt Institute for intentional
thought transformation he's intentional
about his thought transformation he was
these songs
what is the Institute it's him he is an
institution Wow but you're telling me
that Lance knew this guy in person like
it in the flesh Pasadena in mouth
trumpeted when it's late first of all
you know Lance and lacy they meet a
person like dr. Funt they're on it you
know what I'm saying like there's a lot
of people who might be like this guy
he's going he's moving to cabo he's
singing songs all the time but lance and
lacy understand that this guy figured
something out
it's he's easy not only is he just
interesting and entertaining but there's
something going on there
he's manifesting inner happiness through
musical mantra yes in any way and
occasionally a mouth trumpet apparently
yeah I think I think I don't know again
I'm just scratching the surface of the
dr. fun world I don't know how far it
goes a lot of videos yeah well he's been
making videos for like seven years on
YouTube he's got his facebook deal and
he's got a deal with Facebook he's got a
deal he's does with Mark Zuckerberg him
so he's got a Facebook page where he
does the same thing and he seems like
he's got his his his audience which is
not super large but is what he needs to
keep going and anyway dr. fun there's a
wreck Christiaan Drake asked what did I
see in the sky yesterday morning then
post a photo from the phone
what you saw was three three light
sources three sources of light connect
the dots form a triangle that's what you
saw you say you don't think it was
anything suspicious or alien well I
don't have a lot to go on you know it's
a it's a it is just a still image for us
and you're not watching this
guys you don't even see it so probably
nothing Christian Christie Byers asks
what's something that is popular right
now but in five or ten years everyone
will look back on and be embarrassed
about five years is not a long time to
be embarrassed so I'm thinking more 10
years like you're a full decade do you
have something I have something that's
not a it's not like a fashion that's
good cuz I immediately think fashion I'm
like I mean I think my kids will be
embarrassed wearing sweat pants
everywhere just like we were if you you
look at that picture of us Pizza Pizza
and were a surfer my birthday party and
Yui sweatpants for a birthday party and
not only did we have sweaty are you sick
it wasn't that we hit sweat pants on we
had on sweats a sweat suit that didn't
have a name it was just like no no logos
turns out we were ahead of our time it
was like just a gray sweat you had a
gray sweatshirt in great sweat pants on
matching and like Brooks Lee had on like
it was all red or something and we were
we we didn't think he was cool it was
just comfortable yeah it was it worked
are you sick
yeah I was thinking I honestly think
that you know how you go in any social
situation at this point any public place
and everyone's looking at their phone
yeah I choose to believe that it's a
phase I like this I choose to believe
that it is a phase and I choose to
believe it I didn't know you had faith
in humanity like this though I don't
have faith in humanity how on earth do
you think we're gonna get out of our
phones because I think that first of all
we're gonna continue to learn all that
first of all speaking the dr. fun and be
feeling happy and shifting your
perspective shifting your face down into
your phone and doing the the thing that
we all do which is you go from your
favorite app to your next favorite app
to your next favorite app and then rinse
and repeat and you kind of just find
yourself sometimes I just find myself
who's they're gonna Twitter wrote it
whatever just yet it's and and I'm just
like what I'm like standing at the
bottom of my
Aires in my house just standing there in
the dark baby and it's like and I know
I'm not alone and it's just sad what
someone's standing there watching ya
there's a ghost uh it's sad it's
unnecessary it's not good for you it's
not good for your mind it's not good for
your sleep patterns it's not good for
your neck it's not good for your eyes
and I think eventually but by the way I
do think that when I die I want to see a
highlight reel adjust all the times I
just was standing in a stupor looking at
my phone I think that's your point yeah
and I think that we're going to I think
a lot of people are realizing kind of
waking up to the fact that this is all
they do is stare at their hand or their
handheld device but first of all I think
that some things are gonna change like I
mean distant not not sowed in your
future but you know I think there'll be
I've wellgood first of all the Google
the interesting thing is you know how
air pods were really dorky and now it's
like a status symbol and like all the
kids want them it was like oh it looks
like cigarette buds coming out of your
ear but now it's like no dad I gotta get
some air pods the same thing will happen
with displays in glasses right it's
gonna happen it's makes so much more
sense there's gonna be a second wave of
Google glass or something like that that
doesn't make you look like a dweeb and
then everybody's gonna have it and then
people there will be a period of time
where people are standing there in a
daze and they're not looking at anything
because they're looking at their friggin
display in their eyes but I just feel
like we're gonna get to a place where
agricultural Renaissance of wellness I
think we have to um I know and you know
me I'm a I'm all about the future of
futurology the technology and the fusion
the human the human human animal the
transhumanism I think all that's coming
but I think that you can't comment the
expense of our own health and I think
that somebody somewhere along the line
like our kids I think I wake up it's
something we're saying that education
what like they'll be like education for
for kids to like protect them and
they'll be like an infrastructure of
societal positive pressure to towards
wellness not just wellness I mean that's
a that's that's a hopeful view but I am
hopeful but that does happen what
happens is we replace our vices v.i.c
with other vices so there'll be
something like everybody's staring into
their phone and then we'll realize we
shouldn't do that it's just like okay
back when we were in in skin growing up
it's like kids smoked all the time yeah
now kids vape all the time and they say
and they think in the same way that not
us but like back in the late 40s they
thought that smoking was okay for you
and now all these we were like hey it's
faith but they things have been vaping
is bad for you it is bad for you and
they're discovering more and more every
day that it's bad for you you shouldn't
be doing it it's not a safe alternative
to cigarettes and into something else
it's something else we'll replace it but
I so I'm just saying we'll look back on
this moment in time in which we had
these handheld this this idea of a
smartphone
he's so new culturally ten years ago
they were just being introduced right
and he was just becoming a part of
everybody's life we're a decade into
this experiment and we're and we're not
doing well and I think that we're gonna
it might take it might take another ten
years but I think that it's we're gonna
look back and be like man in every
picture everybody's looking at their
phones not cool I hope I like I like
leaving that hopeful note as our last
answer cuz I got a wreck to get okay all
right I'm down I thought that I would I
would not give a music related
recommendation because I you know you
kind of told me I was only giving music
recommendations I'm not hey you know
what I got other things I can recommend
like that diamond real one more day so
oh yeah if you want to if you want to
have a meditative sad experience and you
can handle that like yeah mid-90s
country that's that's a big hurdle for a
lot of people to over quieto might you
might
demon schmaltzy that's not my recs and
effect check baby check baby one two
three four I'm gonna give you a thread
on reddit to follow Oh from puppy to dog
oh yes you seen this no but I'm not
getting a man you can imagine what it is
side by side you got side by side photos
lots of times recreating the photo of
when the when you got your puppy now you
got a big the dog sitting in your lap
and the bigger the breed the better the
change yeah man and it's it's um I don't
know there's like this it's it's
obviously very cute it's very tender and
but it's there is a tinge of sadness
associated with it because it captures
the passage of time and and how its
accelerated in the life of a dog you
know as much as I love Jade like I can't
I can't separate my love from Jade with
the the knowledge that she's gonna pass
much more likely before I will hope so I
hope she dies before me yeah I mean
that's a weird thing to say but you
should you should hope that Jade I hope
you die before me mm-hmm it seems like a
sad thing to say it seems mean almost
but hey so I'm making a recommendation
that if you want if you I mean there's a
there's a tinge of sadness but there's
so much cute and Happiness involved that
it's worth it the funny thing only did
dog the funny thing is is that Jade
would not be a very exciting puppy to
dog because she looks like the day that
you adopted her she's a lot smaller you
know what I'll uh I'll try to I'll try
to find an impost a puppy to dog I'll
try to do that on my shout out on my
Instagram where she was like a third of
the link Lamont she was really little
yes she was almost like hand-sized
wasn't she yeah I mean at least in this
one picture the first picture we I don't
know if that I have to see if I can find
a good picture that I'm in because you
need to have a sense of scale on ones
I'm thinking of don't have a sense of
scale it's just her yeah I memorize see
we took Barbara to like a dog park and
she was tripping over the grass I do
remember that like she was that little
so let's both try to recreate let's
recreate a puppy to dog moment and then
we were going to add it to the thread
are we just gonna add it to the to the
world of mythicality
well my County is like you ever posted
anything to my hat my accounts a secret
account so I haven't created like I
don't know I was like I didn't know what
reddit was I know how I was gonna
interact with it so I just made up an
account like on the spot so I haven't
it's not it's not public and it's not
findable I don't think so
and if you did find it I don't think
you'd you'd be not interested okay
that's another air biscuit again
we don't always do the AMAs and this is
something that we've done like every
couple months or so let us know what you
think about the AMA format I have I have
fun I feel like we go down a lot a lot
of different paths and talk about a lot
of different things to never know what
you're gonna get yeah I'd like to do
more but you know only if you guys want
more so let us know what you think about
the AMA format hash tag here biscuits we
do search that we search it up yeah we
search it down alright thanks for
hanging out with us
thanks for telling people about your
biscuits and recommending this podcast
as well as reviewing it on iTunes
apparently that's still a thing review
to make some stars will talk out you
next week on the backside of our
vacations
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]